[Music]
this is actually a non-technical talk so
hopefully it's it doesn't read this
[ __ ] I don't think it is [ __ ]
I'm gonna talk about the journey that we
went on basically to put ourselves in a
position to do our best work around data
science and algorithms plugged you know
how to how we were able to plug them
into the core of the product and
actually solve real problems which was a
very for us a very long and winding road
we've had a lot of people here today
many of you may know Chris Wiggins who's
like the smarts behind this operation so
you hopefully had a chance to talk to
him and I'm gonna talk about basically
the work that I put in over the last few
years to put him in the best place
possible to have an impact which i think
is pretty important so I do like to ask
a little bit really knows the times but
I'd like to know I'm always curious like
who reads the times like who read who
read something the times on the last
week or so and who subscribes yeah
because I have a theory that we
underserved the technical community
pretty substantially that our coverage
is a little thin perhaps and a little
spotty and comes from particular angle
so I'm always curious to know who's
actually reading that's a problem I'm
working on too but hopefully more to
come on that sometime soon so like I
said I'm gonna talk about our journey
that we've gone on to basically put our
machine learning and data science people
our resources into the best position
possible to have an impact on our
business and I'm gonna start by just
talking a little bit about the times of
I think you all know the times I've been
around for a while you know 150 years or
so a pretty big company now mostly
journalists we've won a lot of Pulitzers
we produce a lot and this is important
this actually goes to the heart of why
this work has been important for us 250
sometimes 300 stories a day now people
mostly interact with us on their phones
and they're gonna see maybe 20 or 30 of
those if you know of our most engaged
readers are going to see the
in a day so we're talking about our most
engaged readers seeing perhaps 10% of
our output in our typical engaged
readers seeing perhaps one or two
percent that's a core problem that we
have we report from all over the world
and we have a big audience at this point
150 million people or so a month
interact with us in some way or just shy
of 5 million subscribers between print
and digital about four-fifths of those
being digital we should cross that
threshold very soon and we're expanding
in other ways as well so who listens to
the daily is anyone listening to the
daily okay so we passed our billion
downloads mark pretty recently it's
probably 1.1 or something by now
so we're reaching a lot of people
through audio we have a weekly
television show called the weekly now on
Showtime and who lose that we're
branching out touching people in a lot
of different ways in fact I was just
speaking to someone who's gonna be
featured whose company is gonna be
featured on the weekly in a couple of
weeks I think so that was the surprising
that's cool so but we're fundamentally
it's important to keep in mind we're
mission driven organization and this is
our articulation of our mission it's
going to be relevant later so I want to
like spend a moment to just take a look
at it what we're here to do is is we
seek the truth and help people
understand the world this mission is
rooted in the belief that great
journalism has the power to make each
reader's life richer and more fulfilling
and all of society stronger or more just
so a lot of companies have mission
statements we actually take this
seriously we don't always do these exact
words but we do look at everything that
we do through the lens of the mission
and are we making progress against that
mission that we're we making the world
better in this way by doing X Y or Z and
that's going to be relevant to some of
the obstacles that we faced in embracing
algorithmic approaches to parts of our
product development we're a digital
company now it's 20 years into our and
really everyone's digital revolution
which is a pretty weird thing to think
about we have a digital multiple digital
legacies now we've been at this for such
a long time
but for us it's really working like we
have really I would say in the last
two-and-a-half years we've really turned
the corner and we really are a digital
business now so like I said four million
digital subscribers a lot of like
getting into new products new forms of
media but I didn't put up on the screen
here is we have a actually extended
digital product line now we have a
cooking product across roots of product
a parenting product a couple more to
come that I'm actually working on but
hopefully we can announce pretty soon
but but we are first and foremost now a
subscription driven digital product
company years ago in a document called
our path forward we set a goal of 800
million in digital revenue by 2020 and
we're just about going to hit it this
year so a year early so are actually
exceeding our expectations on this
journey to being a digital first company
so 2011 is the year that we launched our
paywall and that was a very very
different world if we go back to that
time the digital landscape was all about
the open desktop based internet digital
subscription was maybe just starting but
still look like predominant thinking was
that people didn't want to pay for
content certainly not news so that we
viewed the launch of the paywall very
much as an experiment we really didn't
know how that was going to go or what to
expect consequently our business model
at the time was advertising lead we saw
print subscription being regionally
limited and probably peaked and
declining even at that time we thought
digital advertising was going to be our
way forward but we thought let's try
this pay well let's see what happens
today everything has changed obviously
the world is mobile first we live in a
world where we occupy the niches that
are kind of left by the platforms for us
to play in and we're live in a world
where there's a there's a whole
ecosystem of large digital subscription
businesses at the proven model and we're
actually catching up to a whole cohort
of companies that really paved that way
for us which is wonderful I would say
consumer sentiment has changed there's
clear evidence that people are willing
to pay for content
you know we're capitalizing on that and
as a consequence we're clearly now a
subscription first business we've made a
conscious choice also laid out in that
public strategy document our path
forward that we're focusing on the
subscription business we still have a
big ad business we'll take what we can
get but this is what we care about is
how we think about the product so a
couple of just consequences of that
which we'll get into a little more how
do we how do we how do we grow a
subscription business especially one in
which the piece of real estate we have
to deal with now is pretty much the
mobile phone and we're only able to
surface like the tip of the iceberg of
what we put the journalism that we
produce on that phone on any given time
how do we build engagement in that
environment is kind of the key problem
that we're working on so let's dig into
that a little bit this is a
representation of our customer journey
the top part being how we thought about
it until up about a year ago not a lot
going on there basically we had a pay
wall in front of that pay well we didn't
really know anything about anybody the
pay wall was pretty far back when we
launched it I think it was it like 50
articles a month and we gradually
brought it up until a year ago was at
about ten I think but still there were
like the vast majority of our readers
were on the other side of that pay wall
we didn't know anything about them they
were in this very very opening that
extended consideration period and some
of them like Pete were cheating which is
really disappointing to hear about it's
okay I forgive you Pete by the talk to
me if you want I can hook you up with a
free sub it's cool today we did a lot of
work we thought about this line we
realized that if we're gonna be able to
build engagement we need to actually
engage and activate people we need to
have a relationship with them so we we
pushed up a registration wall and now we
have this interim period where we know
people that like first of all they know
what site they're on they know they've
come to the New York Times they've taken
the effort to register we're able to
interact and communicate with them and
our job our core product challenge now
is to build engagement to get them
coming back to get them using us on a
regular basis so eventually we can you
know take them to the paywall and
they're going to actually
convert that's how we think about our
business that's like the simple problem
that drives growth for us right now
except that it's not that simple the red
walls had a huge impact our population
of Reggie users this is actually the
monthly additions not the cumulative
it's like pops it's very significantly
since we move the Reggie wallet so we
have this big pile of people that we can
engage with and and start to build
engagement and the question is like how
do we do that like what are the what are
the hooks for us that are gonna bring
people in make them commit to us make
them download the app make them engage
with us on a regular basis and
ultimately become subscribers so
recommendation is the obvious answer our
recommendation historically was
incredibly difficult for us and I'm
going to talk a bunch about how what we
did for many years this is actually the
homepage on the web from just six months
ago and it hasn't even changed that much
which is fine and I'll talk about why
but this was essentially our
recommendation strategy for five six
seven years from nothing this is what we
were doing the only piece of this page
that's that's that's personalized is
that bar one that little strip on the
top and it was only personalized under
certain circumstances and it was also
loaded with like marketing messages and
other kinds of things but I was the only
place in the most important service in
our product where we did any
personalization there's a bunch of
reasons why first of all there's a whole
ideology in the news world about the
hierarchy of information on a page like
this and the layout is incredibly
complicated and it's toiled over by
editors and handcrafted according to
like a like long like decades long
established new news hierarchy rules
about importance and we're on a page a
story should code how big it should be
and so on very very difficult to
customize and play with this layout at
all and and that's a valuable feature of
the product it's not just a like old
news tradition it's actually something
that we think certainly our existing
like customers valued which a more
general way to say that is that the
curation of this page was a core value
of the product and remains a core value
of the product so for a long time like
trying to work with
personalizing this surface we kept
hitting a dead end we kept ending up in
these tiny little boxes and we kept
finding either resistance legitimate
resistance to monkey with the layout of
this page because it actually had
curatorial value that's something
something that our users actually valued
further down the page we this is an
example of the kinds of things we would
be driven to is just again like ordering
a set of stories within a certain
category and a certain bar in the page
this is further down the homepage a
section called smarter living which is
like advice and so on and we did a
project that's some of our best data
scientists are working on for quite a
while to just order the stories within
this bar so this was actually the thing
that pushed me personally over the edge
like I couldn't have we had our best
date assigned it's working on a small
piece of a surface and they could do the
most amazing job in the world they could
triple the effectiveness of this bar and
it would have a marginal effect at best
on our overall engagement like one one
and a half percent something like that
so that is the problem that I you know
and along with Chris and others like set
out to solve like how how can we find
the right way when we know that
recommendation is like a core strategy
to use and our core problem of driving
engagement how can we find a way to do
that in the product that is not
undermining other core values of the
product not like running headfirst into
the traditions and practices of the
newsroom because we knew that
recommendation was a key driver for the
subscription giants we'd studied them
this and data is mostly pretty old but
it's pretty striking and I think like we
know this but it's interesting to see
some of the numbers and some of you were
probably from some of these companies
and you know more than I do but Spotify
obviously has driven subscription
tremendously through personalized
recommendation this is again old data
tells us that 30 percent of their plays
are from recommendation they're a year
or so ago were 40 million Discover
weekly users which is probably a quarter
of their subscribed user base or a bit
more than that and they'd spent a
hundred million dollars as we know
publicly on the conus acquisition and
have a large data science team clearly
they believe it's a critical driver to
their growth
Netflix to 80% of their plays come from
recommendation at some point this is
also old data probably a couple years
ago they publicly attributed a billion
dollars of their annual value to a
recommendation and they have a giant
team spent a ton of money working in
recommendation of clearly they viewed it
as a critical growth driver for their
business Pinterest as well critical
driver of engagement for them huge team
big investment and yet here we were with
like a handful of people working on a
tiny fragment of our product and not you
know not able to engage in that way so
so why why is that why did we find
ourselves in that position again we've
talked about the importance of hierarchy
on the homepage the judgment and
curation being a core value of that
product but also like there was a lack
of clarity around the strategic impact
and fit of a recommendation strategy and
I think that focus on the homepage was
reinforcing that lack of clarity so
basically we're trying to like jam a
square peg into a round hole to a large
degree we also have legitimate concerns
over creating a filter bubble a filter
bubble if you're not familiar over the
language is I'm sure you are is the idea
that like you in a news context if you
only see the things that you supposedly
you know quote-unquote want to see your
views are gonna be reinforced you're not
going to be challenged to consider other
viewpoints and so on and you contributes
to the polarization of the country we
cared a great deal about that but we had
not yet set ourselves to the task of
like solving that problem or thinking
about how to mitigate it the last factor
I say would be a perfectionist ideal at
the times mean yeah the times is rooted
in a attitude to quality that is pretty
uncompromising and to get started at a
card problem like recommendation we kept
running into feelings of like oh these
recommendations aren't good enough like
this isn't you know this isn't times
quality that's story why did I get that
story understand and it desired then
like stick our hands in and like tinker
too much with the the workings of the
algorithm or the context that usually
took the form as it did in this case of
a smarter living module like limiting
the universe of content very very
severely so that we felt like we were in
poor control and control the output more
unfortunately undermining the
effectiveness but the other problem was
just that we hadn't asked and answered
the question if like does this work
actually support our mission and if so
how so if our mission is said like you
know help people understand in the world
how how is this actually helping us to
do that and we needed to engage with
that so how would recommendation
personalization help people understand
the world help them deliver the truth to
them or enrich their lives and helping
society stronger or more just we needed
to actually work our way through that
question so we did a bunch of research
over a period of a year and a half to
try to tease out how our readers felt
about recommendation what they thought
its role in the product could be and
should not be and as typically happens
when you do a lot of user research we
got very ambiguous answers starting with
the idea that personalization solves for
FOMO until it doesn't
when end of the spectrum there's so much
here you know I'm only seeing a little
bit like what am I missing and the other
end of the spectrum I'm only seeing the
things that I I know I'm interested in
so what am I missing
personalization only goes so far we only
surfaced so much how do we strike a
balance between feeling like we're
showing the the thing but we're also
showing like the right angle of the
thing the right proportion of the thing
that is meaningful to you so here we
heard users say things like I like that
you and this is a comment about NPR that
you don't know me too well I don't feel
too boxed in by a recommendations but
then well maybe slightly more tailored
news stories would be helpful in an O I
conflict like recognition from this user
that oh I contradicted myself so very
mixed signals we also learned that
personalization means many things to
people
it can mean personal things you know my
history things that I've read before
things that I've saved you know things
that are just mine it can mean optimized
to me in some explicit way things that
I've chosen you know things that are
specific to my location or like
objective facts or prediction base it
can be things that you know based on
what you know about me you think I'll be
interested in and all of these things
blur together in people's mind and
they're not necessarily like separating
them out and slicing them apart
and then we definitely saw the people
had mixed feelings about personalization
and news many people felt that they
didn't want personalization even though
they felt the need for relevance and
more focused in the product we heard
people say things like top story should
stay away from being too personalized I
value it that's what I value about the
MIT is that it's not customized they
liked the curation of the homepage
I think they associated that with being
unbiased so we knew that there was
something there that needed to be
preserved
so what personalized experience did we
feel that readers wanted from the New
York Times subscribers and
nonsubscribers want an idealized news
homescreen that focused on breaking news
in summaries and like the news as its
objective as it could be said to be
objectively framed but then they also
want a variety they also wanted things
that adapted to their interest at the
time of day the mood they were in the
location into their particular favorites
they wanted both of those things and I
think that was a central insight that we
had is that those are actually two
different things
don't try to mix them so that like
pointed us in the direction of a
recommendation product strategy and and
we went from there so starting from our
goals thinking hard about our goals our
core goal being to drive engagement for
that cohort of activated users once
they've signed up they knew you know who
we are we know they are we're trying to
get them to come back every day we focus
on frequency as our core metric the more
often that people are coming to us was
our our key we didn't care if they come
for short sessions and a mobile world
you have to be comfortable people coming
to read one article maybe two articles
at the most but if we can get them to
come back frequently we're achieving our
goal you know
same another way to say that is to
encourage a habit have people opening us
hopefully every day and then we wanted
to figure out how to determine whether
they're like if each session felt
relevant if they found at least one
thing that they found to be relevant
then and now will be regarded as a
success the metric we honed in on was
ultimately one click what like a session
with one interaction was success a
session with no interactions as failure
and that evolved into becoming kind of
our North Star or
our work function and then discovery
which is a very complex incontinence I'm
a contradictory notion we wanted to
actually surprise and delight people we
wanted to drive people down into the
report in different ways potentially
into things that they may not be
interested in but but have a mechanism
to find out and we used to metaphor up
the physical paper here where you could
take the physical paper kind of you know
walk in the door throw it on the table
the sections spilled out there's a bunch
of stories there that you're exposed to
and there's an element of serendipity to
that or pretty like me you read the
paper backwards there's like an element
of serendipity of undermining the
hierarchy and leading to unexpected
results that was missing in the digital
product and we wanted to recreate
something of that we thought about
thinking in terms of recommendation
products so not just features not just
layering recommendation into an existing
product but actually how to like craft a
portion of the product as a full
recommendation experience again Spotify
was a model for us discover weekly is
not just throwing stuff at people it's
within a particular context here's new
music music you may not have encounter
before solving a particular problem I'll
turn to it when I'm ready to listen to
new music etc release radars a little
more focused a little more specific etc
so a series of personal personalization
products is what Spotify screa and we we
were thought that that was very
effective and wanted to find a way to
express that in our world as well again
like clear goals understanding what we
were trying to solve for and then
understanding strategically what role we
were playing in the customer journey
where were the impact points and how
could we really like shift people from
one stage of a journey to another so in
the spring we launched this product
called for you it's a second tab in the
app who has seen this and interacted
with it anybody not to many people so we
still have a lot of work to just hard a
product marketing person but we launched
this product in the spring it's a second
tab so totally distinct from the
homepage and that's again that idea that
there are two things people want we
ought not to mix them we're gonna treat
them separately the user need is
discovery relevance a second reason to
open the app
if in the morning I open the app to say
what's happening what do I need to know
this is more like maybe in the afternoon
you know what else is going on like I'm
like no you know I've caught up on the
news like now I want to learn something
about the world again the metric is
session with or without engagement we'll
take one click and that's fine that's
plenty
and then we also thought that this can
be expressed through reengagement
mechanisms such as email push
notifications in order to bring people
back to the product we have a follow
mechanic that drives the start the
on-ramp for this product quite similar
the thinking is least quite similar to
the way that Netflix uses onboarding
we'll ask you a bunch of questions it's
half just to get you engaged in the
product half to get over the cold start
problem and have an indication of what
people's interests are and then we layer
in information about people's actual
reading habits and you know what's
successful in our like discovery explore
exploit you know what we find that
people actually like over time as we
have that reading history but we've
defined these channels to get people
started to get people oriented a little
bit and that's been successful for us
like that's the first time that we've
had a substantial recommendation product
within the main product we know what
it's for we know how to talk to people
about it we have and we know that it has
an impact so we've seen the lift that it
provides people who are in that middle
stage of the funnel in their customer
journey and we've seen it raise
engagement and it's working so that led
us to think ok we can solve a problem we
can have an impact on the business how
do we go from recommendation from
solving one problem to thinking about an
AML program that seeks the key problems
across the business and organizes us to
solve each of them we worked a lot with
a guy on this named Carlos or eBay who
some of you may know he was one of the
key people doing personalization at the
Netflix for five or six years it's been
a little bit of time at Facebook and
Chris knew him and introduced him we
brought him in to work with us at the
times on half of what he did with what
consultants typically do which is just
tell us what we already thought we knew
with a little more authority
and told you know our executives people
like my boss Mark Thompson the the
things that they needed to hear to
believe what we were telling them
basically but also we learned a lot from
them we learned a lot about Netflix's
journey and how they had gone and then a
lot about how to actually structure a
program and what was important it was
really helpful so we tried to get him to
come in and spend more time with us but
he told me he was like no and I'm gonna
take a break from working I need to like
relax and rest a little bit and I said
oh that's great quick like Carlos what
are you gonna do you know go to the
beach or something he's like no I'm
gonna go back to Stanford and study
particle physics so I was like okay
that's good and you enjoy that let me
know if you need any help home happy to
have you to try he's a great guy so so
we thought about what an apply machine
learning program would look at at the
times and there were a couple of key
things we were solving for though if the
core goal was to identify the key
problems in the business that are
tractable to machine learning and
organize our precious resources around
them
then a structure like this with teams
oriented around specific problems was
what we landed on we've talked about
algorithmic recommendation as one
problem another one that we've started
on later now is is what we're called
algorithmic targeting which is targeting
offers and basically optimizing all of
the key variables in the customer
journey in real time I'm going to talk
about that a little bit more in a second
but the most important thing here was
recognized that this works best when
it's data science led one of the
problems that we had was well-meaning
very smart product managers running our
personalization products but not really
understanding how machine learning works
how items work even how to frame the
problems properly so leaning in too much
saying like I think it's geography like
let's make everything geographically
targeted and then we'd like spend six
months running down a path to do that
only to find out that it didn't have any
impact so we said at the beginning like
these teams are going to be led by data
scientists are going to be data science
and engineering and data analysis
partnerships where but but there'll be
data science lead and they're going to
work it was kind of one removed from the
prod
so each of these teams is actually
partnered with a product team but the
the relationship is mediated through a
clear problem framing it's like the
product managers responsibility to say
okay this part of the product I'm
handing over to you this this surface
here's what we're optimizing for now you
can do whatever you want and and then
it's the data science leads job to say
okay here's here's how we're going to
translate that into a machine learning
problem and how we're gonna actually
build an algorithm to optimize for it
that's proven to be really important and
difficult difficult to sustain it's
inherently kind of unstable there's been
a lot of push and pull from product
people wanting more control data science
folks pushing back and saying okay
you're dragging us into like territory
we can't do our best work so it's
required a lot of oversight and care and
feeding to keep this balance in
proportion but I honestly believe it's
been one of the keys to us actually
making progress on some of these
problems and again like not degrading
into kind of you know hey optimize these
20-story like the order of these twenty
stories in this little box which is the
one of the viruses that we had before so
you know team teams oriented around
specific problems ultimately leveraging
a shared platform and then with some
like executive level oversight to
protect that balance is the structure
that we've that we've landed on so we
talked a lot about algorithm
recommendation algorithmic targeting
probably has the potential to have a
bigger impact on our business we're just
getting started on this this is to like
much of an eye chart probably to read
but this is a representation of our
customer journey mapping out all the
points where basically there's a
variable that we can optimize the value
of that will optimize conversion to the
next stage
the first piece that we've worked on is
at the very end of this process when
we've sold somebody a subscription to
the core product what do we offer them
we typically offer them our ancillary
products crosswords or cooking or
parenting or the all-access bundle so
what can we offer them to maximize the
lifetime value of that subscriber and
you know we saw over 100 percent boost
on the LTV from optimizing that piece of
the journey so
as we go up and we and we optimize the
values of the registration while the
meter count for the paywall
the price the discount that we offer the
period that we offer for how we
transition people from a discounted
price to the whole price all these
variables we think there's an enormous
amount of potential to actually like
substantially move the needle on the
business and we're super excited about
that and then we're looking at our
ancillary products and how to start
layering in algorithm algorithmic
optimization particularly recommendation
into each of those so with cooking we
actually had an intern project over the
summer to create a like recommendation
band of recipes again like this to me
feels kind of like one of those
tinkering around the edges things so but
it's a fine way to get started and
immediately we saw it had a 33 percent
lift in the effectiveness of the
research on that band and a over 10
percent lift on research on that whole
page it was pretty meaningful actually
in his has helped us to drive engagement
in that product we'll be looking at our
parenting product as well in the same
way games is a little trickier to figure
out how to apply but we're gonna take a
look at that certainly we have the
opportunity to optimize the paywalls and
the customer journeys around each of
these products as well so we think
there's a lot of value there too so so
that's where we are that's the program
that we've shaped that's kind of the
journey and how we got there I want to
go back a little bit to talking about
our mission and how we thought our way
through how this work is you know is
valuable to our mission how it actually
moves forward the most important work
that we do at the New York Times so as
we thought of a recommendation there
were a lot of perils I mean this is one
of the reasons why we found it so
difficult to get going there are so many
ways for it to go wrong and we were very
very sensitive to those you know first
of all that comment that we heard from
many users about this tension between
recommendation and the feeling that
something is unbiased was a way that we
could fail and creating a filter bubble
would be a way that we could fail that
we were very attuned to there are other
ways as well the idea of the tyranny of
preference do people just want the same
thing over and over again do they just
want similar
or they want discovery those are very
different problems how do you solve for
them how do you balanced them and then
the idea of like relevant garbage like
things can seem to be relevant but be
superficial be kind of junky this is
what we see all over the web where you
know relevance is measured as a click
you end up feeding clickbait and you end
up with a bunch of junk
that's like superficially engaging but
not sustainable or productive or
valuable so these are like a bunch of
the things that we had concerns about so
we talked about our mission under the
mission is the whole set of values that
we also look at and use as guides and
I'm going to talk about a couple of them
one of them is curiosity the idea that
open-minded inquiry is at the heart of
our mission and all our work we could
believe in asking questions
seeking out different perspectives and
searching for better ways of doing
things so thinking about this we felt
that discovery really was like the key
to this and the way that we could find
that we could fit this work into our
mission in a way that felt genuine and
real so again like on a mobile screen
we're people only going to see 20-30
stories like how could we use
recommendation and that second screening
the second opportunity to open up
people's aperture to really put
different kinds of stories in front of
them to engage their curiosities reward
their curiata its curiosity so that
every time they open the app they saw
something that fed their curiosity that
that gave them like something to think
about something new something new to
experience that felt highly aligned and
motivated us and then the other one was
respect we haven't talked too much about
this but but we've also been looking at
a global audience and how do we become
relevant around the world and this is
what a core like thought in our value of
respect how do we help a global audience
understand the vast and diverse world
how do we do that fully and fairly how
do we treat our readers and our subjects
with empathy and respect and we felt
that like using recommendation to meet
people a little bit half way to say
here's what you need to know but here's
a bunch of stuff you're interested in
was actually a way of showing empathy
and respect for our readers respect for
their time respect for their State of
Mind respect for what they needed in
that moment
and we found that to be also like highly
motivating and clarifying for us so with
those values in mind the what the thing
that got us over the hump was really the
idea that we could use recommendation to
reward curiosity to show respect and to
use those two things to build trust with
our readership and our extended
readership and our new global readership
as we as we acquire them can we meet
each reader halfway in the world in
their journey and whatever moment
they're in can we use the machinery of
engagement not just to drive our
business but to build a virtuous habit
habit of curiosity a habit of discovery
could that habit over time condition and
generate trust could it expand what
people think of us what they think of
our brand what they're there for how
they're able to perceive our mission and
overcome some of the obstacles that we
have with people seeing us in a in a
certain light and you know as a as a new
source of a certain kind and could that
curiosity interest in turn in a small
way help to engender a more
compassionate in just world so I like to
think that's our real goal behind this
program and I like to think it's going
pretty well
and we're just getting started and I'm
super excited for what happens next
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]